with terry mcauliffe running a rough
race in virginia joe biden steps in to
deliver a disgusting attack on glenn
youngkin plus democrats continue to
struggle over their spending package as
inflation sets in i'm ben shapiro this
is the bench bureau show
this show is sponsored by expressivevpn
it's time to stand up to bigtech protect
your data expressvpn.com
ben well you know what's one thing that
you would never do just take your wallet
out of your back pocket put it on the
street and then wait to see if somebody
was going to steal your credit cards now
there's a solid shot that maybe someone
wouldn't steal your credit card somebody
might give you back your wallet or
there's always the possibility somebody
would just take your cash and take your
credit cards and all the rest well if
you wouldn't do that why exactly would
you leave your online data for anyone to
grab this is why you need
expressvpn every time you connect to an
unencrypted network in cafes hotels
airports etc your online data is not
secured any hacker on the same network
can gain access and steal your personal
data this is like passwords financial
details etc it doesn't take much
technical knowledge to hack somebody
just some cheap hardware is necessary a
smart 12 year old could probably do it
your data is valuable hackers can make
up to a thousand dollars per person
selling personal information on the dark
web why do i use expressvpn i use
expressvpn because they've got the
encrypted tunnel that creates that
secure encrypted tunnel between your
device and the internet so hackers can't
steal my sensitive data it's very easy
to use you just download it with one
click of a button and then you fire up
the app with another click of a button
and you're good to go it works on all
devices phones laptops tablets and more
you can stay secure on the go i use
expressvpn you should too secure your
online data today visit
expressvpn.com that's expr.essvpn.com
ben you can get an extra three months
for free
expressvpn.com well joe biden is in some
very very serious trouble the president
of the united states his approval rating
suck they're very very bad he's down in
the low 40s at best on a state-by-state
basis he's really in trouble there's a
pull out from lansing michigan today and
it shows that 67 percent of people in
michigan believe that the country is on
the wrong track compared to just 20 who
believe the country is headed in the
right direction
voter sentiment in michigan is very
polarized 52 of respondents believe that
the state of michigan is headed in the
wrong direction not just the nation
compared to 33 percent who believe that
michigan is on the right track and
president biden's job approvals are now
at 40 percent
52 disapprove in michigan that is a flip
from spring when 50 approved of biden
with 41 percent disapproving asteroid
their personal feelings toward biden the
results were very similar only 39 shared
a positive feeling of the president 49 a
negative feeling
now if people feel negatively about the
president himself the president is in a
lot of trouble because joe biden has
relied for a long time on the idea that
he is warm friendly old joe empathetic
old joe afghanistan killed the joe biden
presidency in a lot of ways i think the
thing that killed most of all was the
sense that this was a guy who cared when
he made that speech comparing his son
beau biden's death to the people who
were murdered by a terrorist in
afghanistan i think a lot of people
tuned out i think they turned off they
said this is not a person who is
sympathetic or empathetic this is a
person who says what he needs to say in
order to get where he wants to go
and that is really coming back to bite
him right now
it's not just people on the right
pointing this out that poll from
michigan is a non-partisan poll john
king from cnn is pointing out if joe
biden remains this unpopular come 2022
the democrats are just gonna get wiped
out
the president's approval rating is down
to 44
his disapproval is at 50
if a year from now the president's
numbers are like that goodbye house
goodbye senate goodbye a lot of
governors races
is that enough to sink terry mcauliffe
right there the president's approval
rating alone
well i don't think so because at the end
of the day virginia is still a blue
state
okay but we're about to find out because
virginia is a very blue state joe biden
won that state by 10 points but if joe
biden's approval ratings are down in the
40s could he drag down terry mcauliffe
absolutely
and and here's the problem for mcauliffe
mcauliffe is basically stuck he called
out barack obama he looks embarrassed by
the president of the united states but
he has to call him out anyway because
otherwise it looks as though he is
trying to run away from the president of
his own party who's about five minutes
down the road
the biggest problem for the democrats
right now is that what the macaula
phrase shows that those suburbs which
democrats had flipped in 2012 and 2008
and then it flipped again in 2020 after
trump in 2016. those suburbs could
easily be moving away from the democrats
again if they start to lose suburban
women the democrats aren't ex they are
in a real
pressing situation again their entire
goal in 2012 was to jettison a lot of
the old white voters they said had to be
left behind in order to forge for a
greater america we're gonna have an
intersectional coalition adam braided by
some college-educated white upper-class
liberals
and this was going to be the new
coalition and suburban voters we'd need
some of them but not all of them and
then trump came along and he did really
well with the rural voters and he did
pretty well with suburban voters not as
well as he could have but pretty well
and then in 2020 because trump was so
personally toxic with a lot of suburban
women they didn't vote for him they
voted for biden but those people are
still up for grabs
there's a good piece of the wall street
journal today showing this
they say races for governor in odd years
rarely illuminate the national political
scene but this year's showdown in
virginia could be an exception president
biden won the state by 10 points
democrat terry mcauliffe is a familiar
face for voters having served as
governor from 2014 to 2018. why isn't he
running away with it that question has a
few answers but the upshot is that
virginia seems like a test of themes for
next year's midterms with president
trump out of office and off twitter can
republicans compete in suburbia again as
soccer moms get fed up with progressive
excess in washington or at their area
school boards or are voters still
worried enough about mr trump to punish
all republicans
glenn youngkin says the wall street
journal has run a strong campaign in a
state that's been moving left for years
virginia's most recent republican high
watermark was said by ed gillespie in
2014 he came within 0.8 or 17 000 votes
of unseating incumbent democratic
senator mark warner in northern virginia
mr gillespie won loudon county by his
mission and he lost prince william
county by three points
three years later he lost to ralph
northam by nine points this time at
loudoun county when democratic by 20 and
prince william by 23.
so what exactly happened there was that
just because ralph northam was such a
great candidate you know with the
blackface and or the kkk hood
no it turns out that that was largely
attributable to the fact that trump was
really unpopular in the suburbs suburban
voters swung away from the gop
in 2018 they kept swinging as democrats
took the house in 2018 they swung again
in 2020.
now biden is in the white house he's
taking his cues from progressives in
congress
they are promising extreme policy and
mcauliffe knows it's a problem he said
earlier this month we are facing a lot
of headwinds from washington the
president is unpopular today
unfortunately here in virginia
and in order to try and go after glenn
youngkin he's trying to tie him to trump
which is kind of difficult because
junkin is a harvard mba he's a former
private equity executive yours flees
fest he talks of killing the state's 2.5
grocery tax and of course he has caught
the wave with regard to ripping on the
virginia public school domination by the
school boards
so what young kin has been attempting to
do is keep the trump voters in the fold
and also reach out to independent and
suburban women
and it's working because right now the
polls have the race basically tied with
all the momentum on young inside okay so
now things have gotten even more heated
because the loudoun county controversy
which was launched by a report by luke
rosiak for daily wire talking about how
the supposed domestic terrorist parents
in loudoun county were pissed off for a
pretty good reason and one particular
parent was pissed off for a very good
reason it turns out that he was lied to
by the school administration it turns
out that the loudoun county school board
lied in full to the parents by saying
there were no sexual assaults in
bathrooms and this is all part of a
broader conversation about whether trans
students should be allowed to use the
bathroom of their choice whether boys
should be allowed to say that they're
girls and then walk into a girl's
bathroom and people said okay well have
there been any problems with sexual
assault in bathrooms of girls and they
said we've never had a report of that
happening and a parent whose daughter
had allegedly been sexually assaulted in
a in a restroom stall
got very angry and then he was arrested
and he was made the face of the terrible
terrible public school parents
and this has turned into a massive
headache for the democrats especially
given the fact that terry mcauliffe in
open debate said parents should not have
control over their kids education so the
two-prong problem for democrats has been
one the failure of the loudoun county
school board to be transparent with
regard to the assault of students and to
the general school board failure to
allow parents to understand what it is
their kids are learning because it turns
out their kids have been taught racial
essentialism in class
and all this culminated yesterday in a
massive walkout at a loudoun county
public high school
students walked out at this high school
to protest the failures of the school
board to protect them
here's what it looked like you can see
this is hundreds of students who are
standing outside the school to protest
the school's failures
it's a school called brood school i
believe
this
received no national news coverage by
the way we had weeks of coverage that
there were like three people at netflix
who are ticked off at dave chappelle
weeks of coverage but you have hundreds
of students walking out of public
schools in loudoun county and that's not
worth one iota of national news coverage
and you know why because it cuts
directly against terry mcauliffe and the
idea that parents and students are out
of bounds to question the school board
or the public school administration
and now it turns out that there is a
a news story from daley wire
specifically talking about the attempt
to go after this girl who reported that
she was raped in a bathroom stall
okay the people who are going after her
include the law firm that used to employ
terry mcauliffe
according to luke rosiak over at daily
wire by the way you should support our
reporting over at daily wire because it
makes an awful big difference luke does
a great job go to dailywire.com
subscribe use code real news for 25 off
because this is the kind of stuff that
the media literally just refused to
cover they had every ability to cover
this instead of covering the story
instead of asking a parent why he was
angry they just decided to pillory him
as domestic terrorists only luke over at
daley wire and the independent reporting
of daily wire made that a national issue
head on over to dailywire.com subscribe
use code real news for 25 off it's
really important
but according to luke's latest report a
law firm that employed virginia
gubernatorial candidate terry mcauliffe
is being paid handsomely to fight
victims of alleged sexual abuse in
schools on behalf of the school system
that the girls say failed to protect
them in one case the huntin andrews
kurth law firm where mcauliffe served as
a senior advisor from 2019 until
recently is battling a young woman who
says she was repeatedly raped on her
fairfax county middle school campus as a
12 year old and that was she was slashed
with a knife burned with a lighter
anally penetrated and gang raped the law
firm and mcauliffe's campaign did not
comment on whether the law firm still
employs mcauliffe mcauliffe did report
income apparently linked to the firm in
2021 after announcing his run for
governor of virginia on december 8th
2020. later advertisements from the firm
from mcauliffe fundraisers referred to
him as a former colleague
the girl in that middle school case said
she was afraid of having her real name
attached because one of her alleged
tormentors had threatened to kill her if
she came forward
the law firm is seeking to have the
lawsuit thrown out because it was filed
under a pseudonym even though there is
no dispute that the school system knows
exactly who she is a judge rejected
hunting's argument but it filed an
appeal on behalf of its client the
fairfax county public schools in a
separate case a girl alleged that after
fcps administrators were told of an
unwanted sexual incident on a ban trip a
school security officer told her there
was no point in seeking criminal charges
and the school gave an award to her
alleged abuser hunton told the court the
school system lost documentation showing
its investigation of the allegations
which occurred in part because it was
not using a sexual harassment allegation
database it had promised to use pursuant
to a federal settlement in the other
girls case
in both cases a women's rights group
filed amicus briefs to express
opposition to hunton's arguments
joining mcauliffe's former law firm and
fcps in the latter case was the national
school boards association which filed
its own amicus brief again this is
against students who are alleging sexual
assault the trio is banking on an
aggressive interpretation of title ix a
law that provides protections in sexual
assault cases that would be more
favorable to school administrators and
less favorable to victims the fourth
circuit court of appeals smackdown their
logic hunting has signaled its intent to
take the case all the way to the supreme
court
again this is
a pretty shocking story and the fact
that it is a law firm connected to
terry mcauliffe is indeed a national
story and you know that the media would
make it a national story except for the
fact that they want terry mcauliffe to
win
by the way you can tell how hard the
media are rooting for terry mcauliffe by
their coverage of the specific case in
loudoun county that has become a
national issue this girl alleging that
she was raped inside a bathroom stall
a reporter for the washington post
tweeted out that this girl had consented
to sex with this guy before now
i'm no me too expert but i was
i was firmly told i mean i was told
reliably
that consent to one act of sex does not
amount to consent to another act of sex
mainly because that's true
okay but the washington post apparently
thinks differently
now they are attempting to
sort of down talk what happened in that
bathroom stall in a sort of bank shot
attempt to protect terry mcauliffe
according to the washington post a
virginia juvenile court judge has now
found sufficient evidence during a trial
monday to sustain charges that a teen
sexually assaulted a classmate in the
girls bathroom of a loudoun county high
school in may
that teenager now 15 is also charged
with the sexual assault of another
student that occurred months later at a
different allowed in school loudoun
county juvenile court chief judge pamela
l brooks said she would wait to sentence
the teen until that case is decided in
november
the case generated local and national
attention after the parents of the girl
assaulted in may said the charged youth
was quote unquote gender fluid prompting
renewed backlash against a policy in
loudoun county schools that allows
transgender students to use bathrooms
that match their gender identity the
authorities have not commented on the
jew on the youth's gender identity it
didn't become an issue monday in court
during the hearing the 15 year old
victim in the first case testified she
had consensual sexual encounters with
the defendant on two occasions in the
girls bathroom at stonebridge high
school in ashburn but on may 28th she
said the two arranged to meet again the
youth threw her to the floor and forced
her to perform particular sex acts that
she was not willing to perform
by the way the his story i mean if the
case is that you're making the case this
is a gender fluid student and this has
some ramifications for who should be
allowed into girls bathrooms
um
there are some facts of the case that
seem to support that
okay apparently according to the article
the defendant did not testify during the
trial prosecutors played up interviews
he gave to detectives investigating the
case during which she acknowledged quote
messing up and said he did not intend to
perform one sex act with the victim and
said he stopped once he realized he was
hurting the girl the defendant initially
told detectives the second sexual act
did not occur but later said it may have
happened briefly and accidentally when a
knee-length skirt he was wearing got
caught on his watch as the pair were
fumbling around in the bathroom stall
really uh really great stuff happening
at these public schools really really
terrific now normally by the way if this
sort of stuff came out about say the
catholic church this would prompt a
nationwide investigation as to just what
kind of sexual assaults are allowed on
campuses and what the cover-up
procedures are but our media seem less
than interested in that particular story
okay so all of this does not run down to
the benefit of terry mcauliffe who have
said again this ties more broadly and
thematically to terra mcauliffe's
statement in a debate one of the most
damaging debate statements i've ever
seen in which she said that parents
should not be in charge of their kids
education instead these dopes who
apparently cover up for alleged sexual
assaulters should be in charge of your
kids education
and well this means that now he is
desperate and he had to call out joe
biden and it did not go great we'll get
to that in just one second first
thieves are pretty innovative at
stealing your stuff the social security
administration computer servers are 45
years old computer servers and health
and human services are 50 years old
maybe that's how cyber criminals hacked
the u.s census bureau's computers where
everything about you is stored see the
threat of some cyber thief stealing your
credit card isn't actually your biggest
risk the biggest risk is he takes over
ownership of your home this is called
home title theft the fbi says it's one
of the fastest growing crimes in america
cyber criminals simply hack into
vulnerable government bank or mortgage
company servers where copies of your
home's title is stored and then forge
your signature saying you sold your home
to them
then they borrow on your home and leave
you in debt you're not going to know
until the collection notices show up
protect your most valuable asset right
the value that you own in your home is
almost undoubtedly your most valuable
asset go to home title lock.com register
your address see if you're already a
victim and use promo code radio for 30
free days of protection again that is
home title lock dot com promo code radio
for 30 free days of protection that's
go check them out and protect yourself
from this form of crime right now okay
so
all this leads up to we are now nearing
the end of the campaign the the election
is next week
and joe biden has called him he hobbles
into virginia his closing pitch is not
that terry mcauliff is going to be a
good governor of virginia his closing
pitch is trump trump trump trump
mctrumpy trump trump trump trump trump
now you may have noticed that donald
trump isn't running for governor of
virginia you may have noticed that
donald trump does not hold any public
office
you may have noticed that donald trump
did not campaign with glenn youngkin
so he has nothing to do with this race
but the democrats have to rely on trump
in order to get out their base because
when trump's not on the ballot their
base doesn't care so joe biden instead
just says trump over and over and over
and over
there's not a trump rally donald trump
donald trump donald trump donald trump
now he doesn't want to talk about trump
anymore
well i do donald trump trump trump trump
donald trump donald trump trump former
president trump's donald trump's donald
trump donald trump trump i love this one
trump donald trump donald trump donald
trump trump trump
okay so what do you think their theme is
are you getting any hints here hey just
say trump over and over because this old
daughtering fool of a president who's
botched the easiest presidency in the
world this is the easiest presidency
ever he inherited a vaccine he inherited
an economic boom because we were going
to come out of the pandemic all he had
to do was sit there and continue to be
barely sentient that's all he had to do
and he somehow blew that
all he has and all the democrats have is
shouting trump's name
that's it
and of course lying about about glen
younkin
because the idea is that you can say
anything you want it by the way this is
how they got trump the way they got
trump is by saying that people like mitt
romney milk toast human beings mitt
romney is the least offensive human
being who has ever walked the earth
truly
he's as bland as a piece of bread with
with not even butter with margarine
okay that that's who mitt romney is and
they call and joe biden got up during
the 2012 campaign and said that mitt
romney was going to re-enslave black
americans
okay the democrats during that campaign
said the mitt romney strapped dogs to
the top of his car forcibly cut the hair
of gay kids
was some sort of cruel bigot and bully
and had binders full of women not
because he wanted to hire women but
because he hated women they said all
that about mitt romney
who is basically dull as ditch water
and so they're going to try and do that
again with now glen youngkin
who again does not match the profile
when you do that republicans immediately
say okay fine whoever punches you guys
in the mouth we're good with
you want more trump that's how you get
more trump but
maybe that's what they want right maybe
the idea is that if we call everybody
trump maybe they'll actually nominate
people like trump in any case this was
joe biden's pitch so he claims that
glenn youngkin wants to ban books this
is just an outright lie it is not true
okay and that's not me saying that that
is the washington post saying that here
is joe biden just lying because he is a
doddering old liar
just a look how he's closing his
campaign
he's gone from banning
a woman's right to choose to banning
books written by a pulitzer prize and
nobel prize winning author tony morrison
okay he doesn't want to ban books
there's no evidence that glenn youngkin
has called for banning books the
washington post said as much now this is
a repeat of a lie that terry mcauliffe
told during debate
and there was a recent decision by
fairfax county public schools to remove
two books one called lawn boy by
jonathan everson and one called gender
queer by maya kobabi from high school
libraries because there were complaints
at a school board meeting because these
are basically pornography
okay but the bill that they are talking
about here does not do that the bill
does not allow parents to veto books or
take them off the shelves in fact all
that the bill which is what is issued at
issue here does
is veto the ability of parents to be
informed that sexually explicit
materials were in the school library
that the school board gets to decide
whether the books stay in the schools
parents can pressure the school board
but the governor doesn't get to decide
which books get removed all that has to
happen under the bill that young kin
supports but that terry mcauliffe does
not is that parents would be informed
that there are sexually explicit books
okay but it doesn't even do that as the
truth okay the truth is that it was only
instructional material is what parents
would be informed about
right the bill that was actually at
issue was a bill that said that if
there's instructional material
containing sexually explicit material
parents can opt out mcauliffe vetoed
that when he was governor of virginia
okay what does that have to do with
banning tony morrison nothing they're
just lying they're just making it up
even the washington post reporters like
philip wegman yesterday he was like yeah
this is not true
but joe biden has to lie because the
idea is of course that every republican
is an emissary of the handmaid's tale
every republican is somebody who wants
women to become of glenn
that every republican is some sort of
brutal vicious
anti-gay
ridiculous person
everybody is trump everybody is trump
you know by the way this is why there is
a certain level of knee-jerk defense of
trump on the right
because we understand we do
that when trump said they're not
attacking
me they're not attacking me because they
hate me they're attacking me because
they hate you
he is right until donald trump ran for
president the media loved donald trump
then he ran for president because they
hated trump supporters trump became
enemy number one
and this is perfect evidence of that
once again they're attacking glenn
youngkin like he's donald trump not
because they hate trump but because they
hate junkin that's the point and they
hate you somebody who's not willing to
vote for terry mcauliffe
joe biden makes that absolutely 100
clear we'll get to that in one second
first right now there's just not enough
workers in the economy and we have
literally 10 million open jobs in the
united states and not enough people to
fill those jobs that means that if
you're an employer it is very difficult
right now to find the right employee
this is why you need
ziprecruiter.com when you post a job on
zip recruiter they send your job to over
100 top job sites giving you access to
their network of millions of job seekers
zip recruiters matching technology scans
resumes to find qualified candidates for
your open roles and then proactively
presents them to you you can easily
review recommended candidates and invite
your top choices to apply for your job
which encourages them to apply faster
according to zip recruiter internal data
jobs where employers invite candidates
to apply get two and a half times more
candidates zipper cruise technology is
so effective that four out of five
employers who post unzip recruiter get a
quality candidate within the very first
day and right now you can try zip
recruiter for free at this exclusive web
address ziprecruiter.com
dailywire that's ziprecruiter.com
d-a-i-l-y-w-i-r-e-zip recruiter.com
dailywire go check them out right now
zipper crew is indeed the smartest way
to hire zippercrew.com dailywire to give
it a try for free okay so then joe biden
gets to the meat of the matter okay the
meat of the matter is that everybody who
is not on joe biden's side of the aisle
is a criminal
okay so in the middle this is really one
of the most despicable things that joe
biden said remember this is captain
unity over here this is the great
unifier not a divider he's somebody
who's going to bring us all together he
was going to be a president for all
americans not just americans who voted
for him who agreed with him i said at
the time of his inaugural when he said
unity there are two ways to interpret
unity one way to interpret unity is
unity
well acknowledging diversity meaning we
all have different opinions on this but
we're still brothers and sisters and we
can respect one another that's one way
to achieve unity
we try to do that on the show a lot
right i have conversations with people
on the other side of the aisle
very nice conciliatory conversations
where we clarify what we agree with when
we disagree with and then we go home
friends right we try to do that that's
that's one form of unity and then
there's the other form of unity which is
sit down and shut up because joe biden
wants to do what joe biden wants to do i
think it is perfectly clear at this
point which which kind of unity joe
biden is seeking
he made that absolutely clear last night
in one of the most despicable things
that joe biden has said as president so
he goes and he's attacking glenn young
and again harvard mba
former hedge fund guy
[Music]
glenn youngkin is not a rabble rouser in
any way shape or form
and
here is joe biden suggesting that glenn
youngkin is equivalent to people who
broke into the capitol building on
january 6th and assaulted police
officers here we go
extremism
can come in many forms
can come in the rage of a mob driven
amount of salt driven to assault the
capital it can come in a smile and a
fleece vest
either way
the big lie is still a big lie
so virginia
show up
that's disgusting and that's truly vile
so you are now comparing glen youngkin
a candidate for the virginia
gubernatorial seat
who is trying to defend parents from the
school boards and trying to stop
children from being indoctrinated in the
notion that america is systemically
racist and he's trying to get rid of
like the grocery tax you're comparing
that guy to people who broke into the
capitol building
paying for mike pence and assaulted
police officers
and then you wonder why the right
just refuses to to
side with the left on anything it's
because of this
i said this the the day after january
6th that after january 6th i said
january 6th was despicable it was
terrible what what people did on that
day is really gross attacking police
officers as criminal behavior criminals
should go to jail
hey i said all of that i also said that
this was going to be used by the left as
the batons wheeled against everyone who
disagreed
it was going to be used and this
happened over and over i told this
malcolm nance did this when i was on hbo
with malcolm nancy did this he said it
was 30 000 people attacking the capitol
building it was not
there was several hundred people
attacking the capitol building at best
and that was a minor contingent of
people who are actually at the stop the
steel rally on january 6. i don't even
agree with the people to stop the steel
rally but the the tripartite conflation
is amazing
it went from
the rioters are bad to anybody who was
at the rally is a rioter to anyone who
supported trump is a rioter to anyone
who is conservative at all whether or
not you supported trump is a rioter
right this is this is the move the move
is you disagree with me and you're
equivalent to a criminal
and then you wonder why we are paranoid
about you labeling parents domestic
terrorists
of course you're labeling parents
domestic terrorists
because after all if they oppose you
they are domestic terrorists according
to you
glen youngkin is equivalent to january 6
criminals
right they're all the same
what a what a vile statement by joe
biden but perfectly predictable because
again he is not kindly old joe
he is a he's a pathetic career
politician who has never earned his own
money a day in his life even the period
when he was out of government he was
earning based on the fact that he had
been inside government
he is a leech on the public trust
the president of the united states is
is a career-long manipulator and liar
going all the way back
and the fact that he was ever seen as
this sort of nice guy is kind of
bewildering to me the american people by
the way now agree with this americans
are not in the mood for the joe biden
nice old man routine because they don't
think that he is a nice old man they
think that he is a venal corrupt old
politician which is exactly what he is
who's masquerading as a moderate but
actually acting as a trojan horse for
radical extremist policy
that's what this presidency is and he's
demonstrating it he's out there doing it
there's something
i would say almost tragic about the
about the sort of images that emerge
from this administration of this this
very
geriatric gentleman
who presents this decaying face
of an authoritarian bureaucracy that
wants to control every aspect of your
life while celebrating itself
it's it's kind of honestly like it's
very sad for our country to have
devolved to this point truly
here's the president of the united
states yesterday jabbering like an idiot
because this is what he does frequently
we're taking a page from terry's book on
his governor and when he'd be governor
next time
we're emerging from this pandemic we
want to expand peak pre-k
for three and four-year-olds millions of
free careers
i don't even know what he's talking
about i love terry mcauliffe in the
background clapping like he understands
what the hell joe biden just said
other than he wants to make trumpet
prefer available to everyone
right this is the person who wants to
control every aspect of your life this
is the person who says that you the
parent should not control your own
child's education
this is the person who says that if you
oppose him and you oppose any of his
policies you're equivalent to people who
assaulted the capitol building and tried
to kill the vice president
that's that's
that's that guy
and when he says that extremism can come
in many forms extremism or radical
political radicalism not terrorism
political rattle radicalism can look
like a daughtering old man who can
barely stumble through a paragraph
and today that's exactly what it looks
like in fact it looks like a bunch of
ridiculous buffoons dancing on stage
and just a quick recommendation to our
politicians don't dance on stage it's
never good i'm gonna have to put
together a compilation of politicians
dancing on stage like some of us know
that we're bad dancers and then unless
explicitly at a concert and pulled up on
stage we just will not dance
and even if that does happen we're
embarrassed that that did happen to me
one time it was very embarrassing uh
when politicians go up on stage and then
apparently volunteer to dance look i
mean look at this you got joe biden in
the middle he's got his coat turned up
because apparently it's cold
and he's bent over
like over himself and then you've got
terry mcauliffe
dancing
like a ridiculous human being i don't
even know what he thinks he is doing
just ridiculous and and all these white
people clapping to themselves
uh
uh just just
uh and there's terry mcauliffe doing the
inflatable man outside the car wash
the these are the
honestly honestly god if you vote for
this in virginia you deserve what you
get uh
i'm with h.l mankin the american people
get what they deserve good and hard
they're getting in california with gavin
newsom where they voted overwhelmingly
to keep him in office and if you vote
for mcauliffe you deserve what you get
frankly
okay meanwhile the democrats are having
trouble putting together any sort of
actual deal on this build back better
plan and by the way there's no public
momentum for it because the plan sucks
we'll get to more of that in just one
second first you know my wife tends to
get really really nauseous in the car
it's a serious problem whenever we go on
a long drive she's checking her phone a
little bit she'll look at me and she'll
say man i just feel nauseous my sister
has exactly the same problem which is
why i got both of them relief bands if
you're looking for a better solution for
keeping nausea out of your life
you have to check out relief band relief
man is the number one fda cleared
anti-nausea wristband has been
clinically proven to quickly relieve and
effectively prevent nausea and vomiting
associated with motion sickness anxiety
migraines hangovers morning sickness
chemotherapy and so much more the
product is 100 drug-free non-drowsy it
provides all natural relief with zero
side effects for as long as needed the
technology was originally developed over
20 years ago in hospitals to relieve
nausea from patients but now through a
relief band it's available to the masses
it works by stimulating a nerve in your
risk it travels to the part of the brain
that controls nausea then it blocks the
signal to your brain that your brain is
sending to your stomach
telling you that you're sick so
basically it just looks like a wash it
looks like a wristband and it stops you
from making nauseous it's like magic
it's super cool as the world is opening
back up don't let fear of nausea keep
you sidelined right now relief band has
an exclusive offer just for ben shapiro
listeners go to reliefband.com use promo
code shapiro you will receive 20 off
plus free shipping and a no questions
asked 30 day money back guarantee head
on over to reliefband.com use our promo
code shapiro for 20 off plus free
shipping that's r e l i e fband.com use
our promo code shapiro for 20 off plus
free shipping already we'll get to more
in just a second first
i don't know about you i'm very excited
that allison williams has now signed
with daley wire so allison of course was
thrown out of espn because she already
had natural immunity from covet and
wanted to get pregnant and she was
concerned about the vaccine so basically
they said it's your job or you're
getting the jab and so she resigned and
we don't believe that it is right for
this to happen to people we believe that
you should be able to keep your job and
make your own personal health decisions
based on your own personal risk
assessment and so we hired her not just
because she happened to be fired wrongly
or left or forced into resignation
wrongly but also because
allison is a really talented person and
if the left keeps canceling people we
are going to keep uncancelling people if
the left wishes to cancel dave chappelle
man i will be on the horn with that guy
so fast it'll make her head swim here at
the daily wire this is what we are going
to do we need your help to do it it's
expensive but it's really important
because we're not just bringing great
content on board for you to enjoy a
daily wire we're helping fight back
against the leftist cancel culture that
is making all of our lives more
miserable if you're on premium
entertainment and sports content without
the woke become a member at
dailywire.com subscribe use code do not
comply at checkout for 25 off we're
building a movement against leftist
hollywood and joe biden's
unconstitutional mandate but we need
your help so go to dailywire.com
subscribe use code do not comply for 25
off join the fight also you know about
morning wire morning wire is great it's
been topping all the apple and spotify
charts but we need your help so if
you're listening you need to go over to
apple and spotify and leave us a review
subscribe start listening right now to
morning wire if you're not on apple or
spotify or wherever you listen to
podcast that helps us keep the show
trending toward the top of the charts
you're listening to the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast and radio
show on the nation
[Music]
alrighty so meanwhile joe biden the
actual radical is out there pushing his
build back better plan and the
conditions under which he's doing this
make no sense
so you have now pretty solid knowledge
that the american people are not on
board with this they are very worried
about inflation and so joe biden is
telling them i'm going to toss more
money at the problem which of course
creates more inflation
inflation is a monetary phenomenon throw
more money at fewer goods and you'll get
higher inflation period and it's
happening all over the economy
for example a mississippi trucking ceo
named john stomps yesterday who's saying
he's now experiencing the worst worker
shortage they've ever seen because so
many people have been paid to stay home
here he is explaining
truck after truck sits unmanned and
unused in total transportation's
mississippi parking lot it's the worst
that i have ever seen how many tractors
do you have parked here because there's
not a driver to fill it we have 910
tractors total in our fleet and today
we're sitting at this as of this morning
where we're 47 open
and ceo john stomp says his worker woes
are minor compared to some of his
competitors
this of course is exactly right muhammad
al aryan who is an adviser to barack
obama he's been a guest on our show
before he says inflation is here to stay
this is not going away it is not
transient anymore
if we're still pumping money into the
system as far as stimulus and you've got
congress implementing trillions more in
spending how can the these prices ever
come down in fact won't they just go
higher final thought
so they will go higher and the fed has
misread the inflation dynamics in a big
way and is still hostage to this notions
transitory but the first thing you
should do is stop
injecting 120 billion dollars every
month it should stop that do we really
need
the fed to buy 40 billion of mortgages
and push house prices even higher
no
okay and of course mohammed el aryan is
correct el aryan has been a longtime
critic of the centralization of fiscal
policy in the federal reserve he keeps
saying the federal reserve has a role
and you guys have basically kicked all
responsibility over to these so-called
experts to generate all economic growth
in the country and it's a huge mistake
and this is what you're watching
happening right now but the democrats
are on tilt at this point the democrats
are just like we're going to throw money
at this problem and they're very upset
that they can't get together on how to
throw money at the problem dick durbin
senator from illinois he says we're kind
of nervous that we're not even going to
get a deal done at this point
it's a
anxious time here on capitol hill on the
democratic side we believe this week is
really the deadline week for us to get
the agreement the basic agreement
done
that has been going on for literally
months
we have so many important issues at
stake here i have i agree with joe
manchin's observation we are close to
the finish line
the president is engaged completely in
this i think we can get it done this
week
okay but if they get it done they lose
because the plan is really bad and if
they don't get it done they lose because
they look incompetent so they've now put
themselves in a box again all joe biden
had to do was just be a tree stump
that's all he had to do he was elected
to be an inanimate object because that
was what everyone thought he was an
inanimate object it turns out instead he
was not a fully inanimate object he was
more like a chucky doll he was just
sitting there on the shelf looking kind
of scary but not capable of doing
anything and then at night he comes
alive and passes ayanna presley's
economic plans it's basically where we
are right now okay there's only one
problem for the democrats of course
which is they have to bridge the gap
between
kirsten cinema and joe manchin and the
progressives which is kind of tough
according to john bresnihan anna palmer
and jake sherman reporting for punchbowl
news let's be blunt democrats are not
close to a framework agreement on their
massive reconciliation package we've
heard presidential biden speaker nancy
pelosi senate majority leader chuck
schumer talk about great progress but
our reporting and the available public
evidence does not match these sunny
claims biden hoped to have a framework
deal in place before he leaves for rome
on thursday without a big turnaround in
the next 24 hours that's not going to
happen this also calls into question
whether pelosi and house democratic
leaders can pass that long delayed 1
trillion bipartisan infrastructure deal
by their october 31st deadline
the white house badly wants to clear the
public works bill as we moderate house
democrats but without the framework
agreement we're pretty sure it won't
pass why because the progressives won't
vote for it the progressives are holding
up the infrastructure bill to get the
much broader build back better nonsense
pelosi says it should progressives say
they'll continue to block it as they
await a social spending deal
another short-term patch to surface
transportation funding could be
necessary
even as democrats struggle to find
consensus on the social spending bill a
path to a deal on both the framework and
the broader reconciliation package is
slowly emerging progresses got a big
boost on tuesday night when reports
indicated the white house would include
between 500 billion and 550 billion
dollars for climate-related provisions
in the reconciliation package
progressives need some victory because
many of their favorite provisions like
free community college have been dropped
or scaled back but it's also true that
after six weeks of studying negotiations
democrats have not come to agreement on
the top line cost of the package what's
in it or how to pay for it
well i mean those would be the three big
issues right how big is it what the
hell's in it and how do you pay for it
mansion and cinema have been calling the
shots on the direction of the talks
individual senators and members have
even taken to negotiating directly with
cinemation in order to win their support
or overcome their opposition to
provisions in the package
while this role for mansion and cinema
has generated enormous outra enormous
outrage on the left biden has been
forced to acknowledge that in the 50-50
senate each senator is a president every
single one so you have to work things
out
they say at the moment yikes
because there is no actual understanding
on how to pay for the legislation at all
senator senate finance committee chair
ron wyden has his billionaire income tax
proposal that he has been pushing it's a
107 page proposal which always is great
it would supposedly impact only 700
americans and generate 300 billion
dollars in revenue but again
what this really is is stealing money
that does not exist because he wants to
tax non-realized capital gains
but mansion might not support that
ironically enough one of the things
that's happening here is that democrats
may pass this bill with the wealth tax
attached so they can pretend that
they're paying for this thing and then
wait for the supreme court to strike it
down
so they can pass a politically
unpalatable provision in a in a broader
bill knowing the politically unpalatable
provision unpalatable provision will
never come to the light of day
so they get the credit for the passage
but they don't get the blame for
actually having to implement any of that
jonathan chad's openly tweeting that
quote the democrats billionaire tax is
probably going to get struck down by the
right-wing supreme court but that can
help democrats pass the bill that's
where you that's saying that the quiet
part out loud right there is that you're
openly passing parts of a bill you know
will be struck down because you're
simply hoping to get something done here
okay so when it comes to the moderates
it's pretty clear they're in control
gensake said yesterday that joe biden
had extra pep in his step after meeting
with joe manchin yesterday which a
little extra pep in joe bidenstep means
that he was merely dragging himself
bodily across the floor
i will tell you the president had a
little extra pep in his step after he
had the breakfast with senator manchin
and senator schumer or leader schumer
this weekend and he was really
encouraged by the agreement about uh
moving forward and wanting to get things
done so it does feel i know for people
watching like this is very messy and
we're never going to get there but this
is always what it looks like when you're
near the finish line
or when you're not near the finish line
actually right actually we don't know
which one that is maybe they're near the
finish line but it looks messy and like
you're not going to get there when
you're not near the finish line and
apparently also when you are near the
finish line for joe manchin's part he's
like i don't even know where i belong in
this party anymore
yeah we know we know joe
have you ever thought my life would be
easier for you if you shifted to being a
republican
and somebody has said recently that um
you know people have approached you
about doing that no i've never i never
thought from this
i i'm
what i'm telling you now is who i am do
you think by having a d or an i or an r
is going to change who i am
i don't think the r's be any more
happier with me than these are right now
okay i mean that's about as
blunt as i can put it so i don't know
where in the hell i belong
now one of the things that nobody is
talking about is the fact that cinema
and mansion don't even agree on taxes so
you might get one and not the other
according to axios the billionaire tax
gained currency over the weekend because
cinema signaled her opposition to
corporate personal and capital gains tax
hikes
manchin has long had concerns about mark
to market proposals which tried to
assess and tax the appreciation of an
asset before it has been sold
and now manchin is saying he has not
seen the text of it so cinema was kind
of in favor of the wealth text and
manchester was like uh not so much
so now senate leaders are unveiling a
separate plan to impose a 15 minimum
book tax on corporations with more than
a billion dollars in profits
cinema is proclaiming her support on
twitter manchin says that he is
comfortable with the plan but that 15
minimum tax is not going to pay for
anything like what they are attempting
to pay for right here plus it is going
to
create disincentives to invest obviously
it says they really do have a mess here
they keep trying different different
methods of basically seizing money
to pay for stuff that no one really
wants okay you can pull the american
public on whether they want things like
free child care or they want free
college they'll always say yes but is it
a high priority for them at this time no
there's no polling data to suggest that
the passage of buildback better is
anything remotely like a high priority
for actual on the ground americans which
is why even if they pass this thing
it's just going to drive up inflation
and people are not going to be super
happy about it anyway
and as mitch mcconnell says right now it
just looks mostly like democrats are are
looking for new ways to tax people
here's the senate minority leader
our democratic colleagues and president
biden are behind closed doors dreaming
up creative new ways to grab
literally historic amounts
of the american people's money
remember the same socialist spending
plans
the democrats claim cost
zero dollars
somehow also need staggering new tax
hikes
to pay for them
okay well this of course is true now
here's the big problem on the other side
well joe manchin and kirsten cinema are
in charge there's every possibility that
the progressives decide to wield their
weight and just say no to any sort of
quote-unquote moderate bill
because remember for their constituents
it's it's still the case that nothing
might be better than something
here is bernie sanders saying that if
this spending bill does not include
dental and vision for medicare which is
a major expenditure and may be on the
chopping block then he's not going to
vote for it so you're trying to balance
joe manchin and bernie sanders in order
again to get a deal done that no one in
america gives a damn about they just
want everybody to be left alone so we
can go back to work and not worry about
whether there are products on the
shelves but instead he got the president
of the united states negotiating with
this communist old nut
bottom line is that any reconciliation
bill must include serious
negotiations on the part of medicare
with the pharmaceutical industry lower
the cost of prescription drugs that's
what the american people want any
serious
reconciliation bill must include
expanding medicare to cut the dental
hearing aids in my glass
okay well chang
wieger who is a big sanders supporter
and who is sort of one of the the big
voices on the progressive left he
tweeted out there's nothing left for
progressives in the reconciliation bill
if progressives in congress vote yes and
then do bs cheerleading for the
corporate democratic party that gutted
it they'll be met with a wall of
skepticism and disdain this bill is now
trash vote no
huh it'll be fun to watch these people
hash it out that's for sure and all of
this is again because joe biden refused
to make clear who he was on day one and
during the campaign it's because joe
biden
finished off bernie sanders in the
primaries and then instead of continuing
to promote a so-called moderate plan he
decided to bring bernie sanders on board
the reality is that the number of people
who agree with bernie sanders in the
united states about economics is very
very low but joe biden is not willing to
stand up to those people because he
wants to be seen as transformational
this just shows you how much of politics
is ego joe biden understands that it is
almost certain that he's a one-term
president i mean he he's barely
stringing together sentences as we speak
he's barely alive
and because he is a one-term president
he knows that he has to do something
transformational if he wants to make it
into the history books otherwise he's
just barack obama's running mate here
now and forever even if he was president
of the united states he is merely the
guy who is the placeholder for whatever
comes next and or the guy who ran with
the first black president and that is
how he goes down in the history books
not as some sort of transformational
figure instead he is trying to go down
as a newfangled fdr or lbj that only
happens if he goes along with
socialistic spending plans and
redistributionist appeals
and so he has decided to cater to the
left wing of his party and now he's
attempting to backfill by dealing with
manchester united i really don't
understand what joe manchin thinks he's
doing here
right if joe manchin even whittles this
bill down to 1.5 trillion how does he
think that's a win for west virginians
does he think the west virginians aren't
going to punish him for moving along
with biden who currently is probably in
the 30s or 20s in the state of west
virginia
the bottom line is this
the democratic party in the end is going
to be forced to run on the oppositional
notion that republicans are the
extremists but the more extreme the
policy they pursue the worse it's going
to be for them and they can't stop
themselves they cannot ever since 2008
they have been committed to a far-left
course
in ever-encroaching far-left course and
joe biden is just the decaying face of
that democratic radicalism and when the
facade falls off
then the democratic party is in the
biggest trouble it has been in it for a
very long time shockingly the democratic
party has now tied its ship to this this
decrepit
elderly corrupt politician and should he
fall down as he is right now he takes
the rest of the party with him all right
we'll be back here later today with an
additional hour of content in the
meantime go check out the michael
knowles show that is available right now
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben spiro
show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
boring our supervising producer is
mathis glover production manager pablo
wydowski associate producer bradford
carrington host producer justin barber
the show is edited by adam sciavitz
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola cristina production
assistant jessica kranz the ben shapiro
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021
the prime minister of new zealand admits
that the purpose of the covet lockdowns
is to create a new hierarchy two
separate classes of people joe biden's
poll numbers tumble in virginia and the
nih tries to cover up thouche's funding
of gain of function research at the
wuhan lab check it out on the michael
knowles show
[Music]